AS WE
ALL KNOW, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
AMERICANS, WE KNOW AMERICA'S
LONG STRUGGLE WITH THE WHOLE
"ALL MEN ARE CREATED EQUAL"
THING THAT WE PUT THERE IN THAT
DOCUMENT.
SEEMS LAKE EVERY DECADE OR
SO WE AS A NATION NEED TO
ASK OURSELVES, YOU KNOW, ALL
MEN, REALLY, ALL?
BLACK PEOPLE, ASIANS,
EVERYBODY, REALLY, ALL?
ESKIMOS, SERIOUSLY?
WELL, LATELY MUSLIMS HAVE
BEEN SUBJECT TO THE EQUAL
PEOPLE TEST,  AND, WELL,
THERE IS GOOD NEWS AND BAD
NEWS.
IT'S THE SUBJECT OF OUR NEW
ISLAMIC AFFAIRS SEGMENT,
HALAL THINGS CONSIDERED.
LET'S START WITH THE GOOD
NEWS.
>> JUSTICES RULED IN FAVOR
OF A YOUNG MUSLIM WOMAN WHO
WAS REJECTED FROM WORKING
AT THE CLOTHING STORE
ABERCROMBIE & FITCH.
>> SHE WORE A HIJAB TO THE
JOB INTERVIEW AND WAS DENIED
A JOB BECAUSE THE HEAD SCARF
VIOLATED THE RETAILER'S LOOK
POLICY.
>> Jon: SHE WON!
SHE WON, IT WAS
DISAPPOINTING SHE WAS PUT IN
THAT POSITION BUT SHE WON.
SHE STOOD UP AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION AND TRIUMPHED
AND AS A REWARDS FOR HER
BRAVE STRUGGLE I'M PROUD TO
SAY THAT SHE CAN NOW WORK AT
ABERCROMBIE & FITCH.
(LAUGHTER)
SHE HAS WON THE RIGHT TO SPEND
EIGHT HOURS A DAY IN A CLOUD OF
COLOGNE SELLING PINK POLO
SHIRTS TO GUYS NAMED CHAD.
SO WINNING THE RIGHT TO WORK
IN A PSEUDO SEXSHOP IS A
PRIORIC VICTORY, BUT THAT IS NOT
THE BAD NEWS.
>> CLAIMS OF DISCRIMINAL
FACIAL OF A MUSLIM WOMAN WHO
CLAIMS SHE WAS DENIED AN
UNUNOPEN CAN OF SODA AT 30,000
FEET.
SHE WAS BASICALLY TRYING TO SAY
TAHTI WHAT USE A CAN OF SODA AS
A WEAPON.
>> Jon: OKAY, SOUNDS BAD.
BUT LOOK, YOU TAKE THAT SODA,
YOU ADD ALKA-SELTZER AND A
SEAGULL AND YOU'VE GOT
YOURSELF A BOMB ON AN AIRPLANE.
I MEAN THERE'S-- THERE'S A
REASON THAT THEY DON'T LET
YOU BRING SEAGULLS ON
AIRPLANES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: THAT'S-- WEIRD, WHEN THE
SEAGULL BLOWS UP AS ITS
APPENDS AGES STAY INTACT...
JUST  THE FEATHERS...
NOW YOU CAN AGREE OR
DISAGREE WITH THE AIRLINE
POLICY OF DISTRIBUTION OF
UNOPENED CANS BUT ARE WE
REALLY SURE THIS IS
DISCRIMINATION.
>> SHE ASKED THE MAN NEXT TO ME
WHAT HE WOULD LIKE TO DRINK,
AND HE REQUESTED A CAN OF
BEER.
AND SHE, I NOTICED THAT SHE
PLACED IT IN FRONT OF HIM
AND IT WAS A CLOSED BEVERAGE
CAN.
>> Jon: OKAY, OKAY, SEEMS
LIKE A DOUBLE STANDARD.
BUT YOU THINK ABOUT T WHEN
HAS A WHITE GUY POUNDING
BEERS ON AN AIRPLANE EVER
LEAD TO VIOLENCE.
IT'S JUST-- I'M BEING TOLD
ALMOST EVERY TIME --
ALMOST EVERY TIME.
WELL, THIS SOUNDS LIKE A
HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE.
BUT AS WITH ANY SITUATION
INVOLVING A MAJOR AIRLINE,
IT COULD ALWAYS GET WORSE.
>> I ASKED THE PASSENGERS
AROUND ME, I SAID, DOES
ANYONE WITNESS WHAT SHE JUST
SAID TO ME.
I SAID HOW DARE YOU SAY THAT
I WOULD USE IT AS A WEAPON.
AND THEN A MAN SITTING, YOU
KNOW, ACROSS FROM ME SAID
YOU MUSLIM, YOU NEED TO SHUT
THE F UP.
[AUDIENCE GROANS]
>> Jon: THAT IS-- I'M SCOCKED AT
WHAT GOES ON IN COACH.
BOY.
AM I RIGHT?
I MEAN IT'S-- CAN'T YOU JUST
SAY, CAN'T YOU JUST SAY TO
THE PERSON, COME ON, CALM
DOWN, THE SUNDAYS WILL BE
OUT ANY MINUTE, ALONG WITH
THE LIVE MUSIC.
FRANK SINATRA!
YOU KNOW, IN COACH HE'S STILL
DEAD, BUT IN FIRST, FLY ME TO
THE MOON.
WELL, IF THERE WAS ANY
AMBIGUITY OF WHETHER OR NOT
THIS INCIDENT HAD A
DISCRIMINATION COMPONENT,
OLD F-BOMB JOHNSON TOOK CARE OF
THAT.
AT LEAST NOW THE FLIGHT
ATTENDANT WILL SHUT THAT
DOWN.
>> THERE WAS NO BYSTANDER
INVENTION.
AND THE FLIGHT ATTENDANT
DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING TO HIM
EITHER.
>> Jon: OH.
I FEEL BADLY FOR THIS WOMAN.
FOR MORE WE'RE JOINED BY
SENIOR RELIGIOUS
CORRESPONDENT HASAN MINHAJ.
HASAN, THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THIS IS A SHOCKING STORY, THAT
TAHARA AHMED, WAS ON A FLIGHT.
SHE'S AN AMERICAN CITIZEN,  AN
INTERFAITH CONDUCTOR AT THE
NORTHWESTERN UNIVERSITY.
HOW DOES SHE NOT HAVE THE
RIGHT AND FREEDOM TO ENJOY
ONE OF OUR 12 OUNCES OF
DELICIOUS SUGAR WATER.
>> JON, ACTUALLY, THE
AIRLINE DID THE RIGHT THING.
YOU CAN'T RISK PASSENGER
SAFETY JUST TO GIVE IN TO
ONE WOMAN'S CRAZY DEMANDS.
>> Jon: SHE ASKED FOR A CAN
OF SODA.
>> OKAY, JON, YOU MEN A
CARBONATED GRENADE?
ALL RIGHT, YOU THROW THAT AT
SOMEONE, BAM, THEY ARE OUT
LIKE A TROUT.
>> Jon: YOU HAVE JUST THROWN
AWAY YOUR ONE WEAPON.
>> YEAH, BUT THEN YOU ASK
THE FLIGHT ATTENDANT FOR
ANOTHER CAN OF SODA, 198
SODA CANS LATER, THE PLANE
IS YOURS.
I MEAN, EVEN LESS IF IT'S A
COMMUTER FLIGHT.
>> Jon: HASAN I DIDN'T REALIZE
MUSLIMS WERE SODA CAN
MACGYVERS.
>> WE'RE CRAFTY, YES.
ANYTHING ON A PLANE IS A
WEAPON TO A MUSLIM, ALL
RIGHT.
THE CORNER OF A DORITO CHIP
CAN SLICE THE NECK.
YOU THINK THAT SEAT CUSHON
IS A FLOTATION DEVICE?
YOU  ARE WRONG, THAT IS A
SMOTHERING PILLOW.
YOU SEE A SKYMALL, I SEE A
PAPER CUT CATANA.
>> Jon: THIS WOMAN WASN'T
TRYING TO TAKE OVER THE
PLANE.
SHE WAS WEARING A SCARF,
THAT IS ALL.
>> AROUND HER HEAD.
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> SCARF AROUND THE HEAD IS
WAY SCARIER THAN SCARF
AROUND THE NECK.
BIG DIFFERENCE, OKAY.
ALLOW ME TO DEMONSTRATE
USING JUST A LITTLE PROP
HERE.
THIS IS A STANDARD SCARF
RIGHT HERE.
THIS IS GOOD, OKAY.
THIS IS GOOD.
NOT GOOD, OKAY.
GOOD, NOT GOOD, OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
FUN, SCARY.
>> Jon: OKAY.
>> THIS RIGHT HERE SAYS I'M
AUDREY HEPBURN, GALAVANTING
AROUND THE PLAZA.
THIS IS AS I'M HERE TO KILL
AUDREY HEPBURN WHILE SHE
GALAVANTS AROUND THE PLAZA.
>> Jon: I DON'T THINK THAT'S IT.
BUT THIS S LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING, THIS IS AMERICA,
FROM EVERYTHING THAT I HAVE
LEARNED ABOUT AMERICA, WE
LOVE PEOPLE OF FAITH.
THAT'S WHAT WE LOVE.
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IF IT IS THE RIGHT ONE.
NOW THERE IS A HIERARCHY OF
FAIFT IN THIS COUNTRY.
UP TOP WE HAVE EVANGELICAL.
THEN CATHOLIC, JEWY BUT NOT
TOO JEWY, MISCELLANEOUS
NONMUSLIM, SCIENTOLOGY,
DEVIL WORSHIP, THEN RIGHT
DOWN HERE IS MUSLIM.
>> Jon: OH, SO ARE MUSLIMS
SUPPOSED TO HIDE THEIR FAITH?
IS THAT THE IDEA?
>> GREAT IDEA.
THAT IS A GREAT IDEA.
WHICH LEADS ME TO MY NEXT
SEGMENT, MINHAJ'S MUSLIM
MAKEOVER.
>> Jon: THAT SAY REALLY
PRETTY GRAPHIC.
>> YOU LIKE IT?
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THE
BRANDING.
ANYWAY STEP NUMBER ONE --
CHANGE YOUR NAME.
NOW -- THIS IS A SERIOUS THING.
IF YOU ARE MOHAMMED, GO BY
MOE.
SALOMON, SAL, FATIMA YOUR NAME
IS NOW CRAIG.
>> Jon: CRAIG?
THAT SEEMS HUMILIATING, HASAN.
>> IT IS.
CALL ME CODY, JON.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT.
>> STEP TWO -- IF YOU ARE A MAN
YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW MY LEAD
HERE AND HIDE YOUR BEARD.
>> Jon: YOU DON'T HAVE A
BEARD.
>> ON THE OUTSIDE.
MY BEARD IS ACTUALLY ON THE
INSIDE OF MY MOUTH.
I'M CONSTANTLY JOKING, JON.
NOW, IF YOU ARE A MUSLIM WOMAN
FLYING ON A PLANE, THINGS GET
MORE COMPLICATED.
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE THE GAME.
FIRST THINGS FIRST, YOU HAVE
TO GET YOUR HIJAB. NOW THAT
IS GOING EXPOSE YOUR HAIR, SO
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE THAT, TOO.
WE'RE GETTING THERE.
NOW THE NEXT STEP IS GETTING
RID OF ALL THOSE CLOTHES.
REMEMBER, COVERED IN FABRIC
MEANS COVERED IN SECRETS.
SO WEAR SOMETHING A LITTLE
MORE AMERICA-LOVING.
THAT IS THE TICKET.
THAT'S THE TICKET.
NOW THAT IS A MUSLIM THAT ET GOS
AN UNOPENED CAN OF SODA.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT.